[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Jean Ross vice
president of evangelism for amazing
facts
hello frames how about an amazing fact
on Thanksgiving Day 1936 two Minnesota
boys named Harold and Charlie Peterson
decided to go hunting with a man who
worked on the family farm the two
brothers and the companion were good
hunters but accidents can happen to the
best marksman and that day a bullet from
the hired man's gun accidentally struck
Harold in the face opening a large hole
in his cheek when the wounded youngster
reached the hospital it was found that
the bullet had lodged at the base of his
skull so near the spinal cord that
doctors did not dare to operate to
remove it the 15 year old boy was told
that he would have to take his chances
and live with the bullet in his body for
the rest of his life fortunately it gave
him no real trouble and in time he
almost forgot about it then in 1960
Harold now 39 years old and running the
same family farm felt that he might be
coming down with a sore throat a few
days later he had a violent coughing
spasm he coughed and coughed and finally
coughed up a bullet he has the same
soft-nosed rifle bullet that had lodged
in his neck 24 years before friends did
you know that the Bible speaks of things
often forgotten coming back stay tuned
for more as amazing facts brings you
this edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 seven two nine
seven we're gonna say that again that's
800 four six three seven two nine seven
that'll bring you here into the studio
and you can ask your Bible question on
the air we're gonna give you another
phone life own number as we get into the
program that is our resource line and we
have a number of free resources I would
like to make available to those of you
who are listening and that number is 885
six seven four seven I'll repeat it
during the program 808 three five six
seven four seven that is our resource
phone line now open the program by
talking about a young man who had a
bullet lodged at the base of his skull
for Oh a number of years 24 years that I
was there until finally almost forgot
about it but then one day he coughed up
the bullet now it's interesting to note
that in the Bible Jesus said that there
would be things that people would forget
about which would actually come back in
Matthew chapter 12 verse 36 we read
Jesus speaking but I say unto you that
every idle word that men shall speak
they shall give an account thereof in
the day of judgment for by your words
you are justified and by your words you
are condemned we also have a reference
to this judgment
in Ecclesiastes chapter 12 verse 14
where we read God shall bring every work
into judgment every secret thing whether
it be good or whether it be evil in
other words every detail of life will be
reviewed including those secret thoughts
and words and actions even those things
that people have forgotten about this
will happen of course at the judgment it
will confirm who will be saved and who
will be lost it is true that we are
saved by grace but it is also true that
we are judged by our works because our
works are a manifestation of our faith
in James chapter 2 verse 18 we read but
someone will say you have faith and I
have works show me your faith without
your works and I will show you my faith
by my works now friend you might be
wondering about this judgment that the
Bible speaks of yes it's true that every
secret thing according to the Bible will
be reviewed but what about one who
believes in Christ those who have
received Jesus as their personal Savior
what assurance do we have in the
judgment well there's good news the
Bible presents the judgment as good news
for those who have faith in Jesus we
have a study guide that'll tell you all
about this it's free we'll be happy to
send it to anyone who calls and asks the
study guide is called case closed and it
talks about those judgment that we read
about in the Bible if you'd like to
receive a free copy of this study guide
all you'll need to do is call our
resource phone line that's eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
and you can ask for the study guide
called case closed and we'll be happy to
send it to anyone in North America if
you're outside of North America maybe
you're watching this on Facebook and
you'd like to read that study guide just
go to the amazing facts website it's
amazing facts dot o-r-g and you can type
in the search bar case closed
and that'll take you to our study guide
dealing with the judgment what does the
Bible say about the judgment well we're
ready to take our first caller for this
evening we have Kalyn listening from
Florida
aquiline welcome to the program thank
you so much I have a quick question
about freewill okay and I decided that
we don't happy well and I wanted to you
know understand these verses a little
bit more so I can kind of give her a
better understanding of what they
actually mean and not really the face
value of it so the background that she's
coming except she's saying that she's
looking from a deterministic view and
she said we cannot help our desires
therefore we can't help what we don't
want or do want and we can't really
choose God based off of that and that
thought has chosen those who will be in
the kingdom and she uses verses from
Romans nine so verses 15 through 19 I
just want a better understanding of that
and so if you could explain it a little
bit for me I'd appreciate it so much
thank you
sure you're talking about Romans chapter
9 and you mentioned verse 15 and let me
read the verse for those who might be
driving it says for he says to Moses I
will have mercy on whom I have mercy and
I will have compassion on whomever I
will have compassion so it is not him
who wills nor of him who runs but of God
who shows mercy so the question here is
do we have any choice with reference to
whether or not we going to be saved well
you know if you look at everything the
Bible has to say about salvation it's
very clear that we have a part to play
we have freedom of choice God gives us
the ability to choose to serve Him
specifically here in Romans this idea of
predestination or one being called isn't
referring to an individual salvation
rather it is referring to God choosing
Israel as his chosen people it was
nothing special that Israel had done but
God chose them he chose to have mercy on
them he chose to bring them to the
promised land it was through Israel that
the Messiah was to come so the whole
argument that we find enrolments is not
an
Jil that god is choosing above someone
else but rather he's talking about God's
people the Jewish people that had been
chosen by him through whom the Messiah
was to come right and then with hmm
because she really hung on to that verse
where it says you know Satan even I'm
reading from the New King James Version
you say to me then why do people find
fault for who has resisted as well again
the context there is talking about
Israel in particular and the other
nations around them so God chose Israel
to be his chosen people through whom the
Messiah was to come again Paul likens it
to the descendants of Abraham Ishmael
and Isaac and it says Isaac I have loved
Ishmael I have hated and that's not
talking specifically about the
individual but Ishmael Isaac represent
the two nations that came from Abraham
God had chosen Isaac and his descendants
to be the one through whom the Messiah
was to come and then and my thumb
because I'm sure she'll bring up
computer as well yes now of course it's
prophesied that one of Christ's own
would betray him you read about that in
Psalms but once again it's not that God
purposely predetermined that Judas
didn't have any choice in the matter he
was destined to betray Christ no Jesus
reached out to Judas we read in the
upper room Jesus even washed the feet of
Judas Jesus did everything that he could
to try and reach him God knew what Judas
would decide to do but God did not force
Judas to do that he still had freedom of
choice so God knows the end from the
beginning he knows who's gonna be saved
and who's gonna be lost because he knows
everything but just because he knows
what choices we gonna make he doesn't
force us to make those choices
we still have freedom to make those
choices and then well thank you so much
that's it all right well good question
important question you know we do have a
book that deals with this and we'll be
happy to send this to you
kaeleen or anyone that might want to
know more about it it's simply called
canna save manchu
to be lost talks about free will and
will be happy to send that to anyone who
calls and asks again the number that you
need to call is a resource phone line
that's eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven you can ask for the
book can I save man choose to be lost
annex Kula that we have is Mike and Mike
is joining us I believe in Indiana Mike
welcome to the program good evening
pastor Ross hi welcome to the program my
question has to do with um over
righteousness by faith and how that
Christ is our high priest our righteous
you know high priest in the heavenly
sanctuary yes and how that like in
Genesis we see Noah had an ark and that
o Moses there was an ark there and then
the Ark of the Covenant and then now in
our days there is an ark in the heavenly
sanctuary and we know that Christ is
before the throne of God presenting his
blood in our behalf as the believers of
the the last days here my question is as
he bids us to follow him wherever it
wherever he goes and we know that he you
know he wants us to be in the in the
heavenly sanctuary as far as the bread
and the and the oil flowing through the
lamp the holy spirit flowing through us
in our lives and then the prayer life we
have the communication we have with with
God but is it could it be or am I just
thinking this too deep or crazy or
whatever but is Christ bidding us to
follow him into the Holy of Holies I
mean he did say he's making us a kingdom
of priests and or am i way off base on
that or no no I think you know you're
correct let me back up a little bit for
those who might be new to the idea of a
heavenly sanctuary in Jesus as our high
priest ministering for us we're reading
the book of Hebrews in the New Testament
very clearly that there is a heavenly
sanctuary there God built and that the
earthly tabernacle that we read about in
the Old Testament was a shadow of this
heavenly sanctuary that God built the
work of the earthly priest was a type of
the work that Jesus does as our high
priest now in the heavenly sanctuary now
the earthly sanction
which was a shadow they heavenly
contained three parts you had the
courtyard area that's where the lamb was
actually sacrificed you had the holy
place that was the first compartment of
the sanctuary where there was a table of
showbread there was a seven-branch
candlestick there was also an altar of
incense and then a veil and then behind
the veil you have the most holy place
and that's where the Ark of the Covenant
was kept and on the Ark of the Covenant
was the mercy seat and there were angels
inside the Ark of the Covenant was where
the Ten Commandments were now the outer
courtyard of the sanctuary represents
the work that Jesus does for us here on
this earth that's where the lamb was
sacrificed Jesus came to the earth he
died as our lamb the Lamb that takes
away the sins of the world when Jesus
rose from the dead and ascended to
heaven he started his work as our high
priest ministering for us in the
heavenly sanctuary and just like the
earthly priest had work in the first
compartment and then once a year he
would going to the most holy place so we
find Jesus ministering for us in
Revelation chapter four and five in the
first compartment but then when you get
to Revelation chapter 11 now you find
Jesus in the most holy place by the Ark
of the Covenant by faith we are to
follow Jesus just as the Israelites were
to follow their priest by faith into the
most holy place they couldn't actually
go in person but they they were paying
attention to when the priest would go
into the most holy place they would
confess their sins they would make sure
that their lives are right with God so
it is now that believers by faith follow
Jesus into the most holy place meaning
that we confess our sins we exercise
faith in him as our priest as our
sacrifice as our Lord we come into our
right relationship with him
so the earthly sanctuary is a shadow and
a type of the heavenly yes thank you
very much Pastor Ross it's because it's
like you by beholding we become changed
so that's awesome that's right there's a
lot of wonderful truths that one could
learn from the sanctuary and you see its
significance in the Bible Mike thanks so
much for your call if you'd like to
learn more
about this heavenly sanctuary and what
Jesus is doing for us right now in
heaven we have a study guide called God
drew the plans it's all about the
sanctuary and its significance we'll be
happy to send it to anyone who calls and
asks once again the phone line our
resource phone line is 883 five six
seven four seven and you can just ask
for the study guide called God drew the
plans or you can read it for free online
at the amazing facts web site a next
caller is Katie listening from
Bakersfield Katie welcome to the program
hi hi thanks for calling I have a
question I have a question on the second
Corinthians 2 important the last part
for the children ought not to lay for
the parents but parents to their
children
do I understand it right that parent
should not lay for their children nor
does the opposite we parents have to lay
for our children but some people said
why do we have to and we already sent
them to school and they were already on
their own so what what do you think what
exactly does that mean yes it's just
stating the typical tradition and you
know you'll find out probably in every
culture and around the world that the
children of the parents eventually
inherit that which was the parents it's
not that the parents inherit that which
is the children obviously it would be
the children that inherit that which is
the parents now having said that that
doesn't mean the children don't have a
responsibility to take care of their
parents when they are old
the Bible's quite clear on how one is to
treat the elderly and how children have
a responsibility to do what they can to
take care of the needs of their parents
but this verse in particular that you're
referring to in 2nd Corinthians is
simply stating the typical tradition
that you know children receive an
inheritance from their parents so we got
it right so thank you thank you for this
explanation yes how I told good question
thank you for calling Katie our next
caller that we have is Becky and she's
listening from Michigan Becky welcome to
the program
hello pastor shine how are you doing
well thank you I have a question out of
poverty 1810 okay let me look it up and
we'll really care for those who might be
driving proverbs chapter 18 verse 10
says the name of the Lord is a strong
tower the righteous run to it and are
safe now your question what exactly is
the man it's like protection good
question
well back in Bible times of course you
know when proverbs was written by
Solomon you had a number of city-states
that were scattered around the area of
the Middle East and often when there
were people outside of the city you had
people in the city that lived in the
city but then you also had people
surrounding area outside the city many
of which took care of the farms and
those type of things but in the event
that there was an army that approached
an enemy army that was coming those who
were outside of the city would rush into
the city and of course there would be
towers they run into the city and that
would be their place of refuge and
safety from the enemy so that same
imagery is used here and it says the
Lord is a strong tower that means for
the believer the righteous run into it
and are safe just like the people that
were living outside the city when the
enemy was coming and they ran into the
city and they found safety so we as
Christians when we face temptation and
trials we had to run to Jesus we run to
Jesus to find safety he will give us
victory as is promised we come to him in
prayer that's how we run to Jesus we run
to him in prayer we can claim some
promises from the Bible and we can have
deliverance we can have strength does
that make sense Becky yes it does all
right thank you
absolutely good question thanks you call
my next caller that we have is sandy
listening in Illinois sandy welcome to
the program hi pastor as I struggle with
Bible dichotomies in other words things
on the surface that look like they're
the exact opposite for example in this
is King James
Luke chapter 4 verse 12 and Jesus
answering said unto Him it is said that
shalt not tempt the LORD thy God
well then going to Exodus chapter 17
verse 2 where the people were
complaining or chiding with Moses and at
the end it says where so do you tempt
the Lord so in context I'm guessing that
means tempting the Lord and then verse 7
the end of that verse it says and
because they tempted the Lord saying is
the Lord among us or not and when Isaiah
1:18 regard invite us to come and reason
together and I struggle with this and
I'm just trying to find tools and the
right attitude and the right spirit to
rightly divide the word but so I can
know the true identity of God because
you know what kind of the Old Testament
New Testament on the Old Testament he
was like this great big angry gonna get
you're gonna zap you and in the New
Testament but Jesus said so I don't know
how to love tear these two into each
other so that it's like it should be
yeah let me share a few thoughts on this
first of all Luke chapter 4 verse 12
Jesus is quoting from the Old Testament
he's actually quoting here from
Deuteronomy chapter 6 verse 16 where he
says it has been said you shall not
tempt the Lord your God now what does
meaning when it says tempt the Lord your
God you can another word that can be
used in place of tempt means to test or
try all provoke so despite all the
blessings that God had given the
children of Israel he had open up the
Red Sea he had fed them manna from
heaven he provided water from the rock
despite all of the many blessings that
God was giving to the Israelites in
their wilderness wanderings they still
rebelled and doubted his goodness and
there were several times where they said
oh I wish we could have died in Egypt oh
that we could have gone back they said
all I complain to the Lord and said
you've brought us out into the
wilderness so that we could die by the
enemies that they encountered on their
journey and the Bible says don't tempt
the LORD thy God in other words
recognize
God's blessing look at his goodness we
can always choose if you want to dwell
upon the goodness of God or we can doubt
and to tempt God is to doubt God's
goodness to doubt his love and that was
a challenge of finding the Old Testament
time and time again even amongst those
who profess faith in Jesus
whenever trials came their way instead
of trusting God and looking to him for
deliverance they began to doubt God's
goodness and they began to complain and
that's what it means when it says don't
tempt the Lord your God be faithful even
in trials and difficulties God loves you
he will take care of you now of course
the god of the Old Testament is the same
god of the New Testament Jesus said if
you have seen me you've seen the father
if you want to know what God's like look
at Jesus many times in the Old Testament
we have so many examples of God's
patience and forbearance his compassion
even in the Old Testament laws that were
given many of the laws related to even
the strangest and the poor and the
widows and how people were to take care
of them you can see God's compassion
even in the laws that he gave in the Old
Testament there are some cases where
there were judgments where God did bring
about judgment upon the earth in the
case of the flood and sometimes some of
the nations that were rebelling against
him but despite those judgments you can
still see God's mercy and God's love in
preserving a remnant and that was
necessary in order for there to be a
remnant who still served him okay so
it's just like choosing to see the glass
half full and not half empty yes that's
a that's a good analogy you know if we
dwell upon all of our problems our life
could be pretty discouraging and we'll
be tempted to think God doesn't love me
doesn't care about me but we look at all
the blessings we look at what God did to
save us we look at what he's promised us
in his word that he'll never leave us
nor forsake us we look at the promise if
we confess our sins he's faithful and
just to forgive us and cleanse us if we
dwell upon those wonderful promises our
faith will be revived and will be
strengthened to stand faithful to him
okay thank you all right thank you for
your call sandy we appreciate that I
think we have time for one more caller
before we take our break we have William
listening from Illinois William welcome
to the program hi thank you very much
for taking my call my question is this
if one is been saved that can they lose
their salvation yeah that's basically my
question okay the answer to that is
after a person is saved they don't lose
their freedom of choice God doesn't
force someone to remain in a saved
condition if they choose not to remain
in a safe condition in other words God's
not going to force somebody to go to
heaven if they choose not to go to
heaven even if one time they were
forgiven and they did call upon the name
of the Lord and they were saved so just
like we have freedom before we choose
Jesus we still have freedom after we
choose Jesus that's why Jesus says we
must abide in him it's only through
abiding in him day by day that we're
able to grow and be able to flourish
spiritually Jesus said he that endures
to the end shall be saved we need to
connect ourselves with Christ Jesus said
except you eat my flesh and drink my
blood you have no life in you and the
people said boy this is a hard saying
who can understand it then jesus said
the words that I speak to you they are
spirit they're life in other words we
need to receive the word of Christ we
need to allow his word to revive our
hearts that's what it means to abide in
Jesus so yes
the Christian we choose Jesus as our
personal Savior we want to abide in
Jesus and as long as we remain faithful
to Christ we abide in him we exercise
faith in Him we believe in him as our
personal Savior we are saved you know we
can trust in God's goodness but it
doesn't mean we don't have freedom to
choose another master if we desire to do
so
well my question then would be do you
know personally of your own experience
someone who's chosen another master
after once they've been saved through
Jesus
sacrifice well we have some we have some
individuals in the Bible who at one
point they were saved they were even
filled with the Holy Spirit and they
prophesied I don't think you can have
any more evidence as someone who is
saved but they eventually turned away
from God and they were lost who were
these people
I don't know well for example you got
Kings soul he he rebelled no I I'm
talking about in the New Testament in
the New Testament you've got yeah you've
got Judas that was filled with the Holy
Spirit
he went out performing miracles and yet
he turned against Christ and betrayed
him um okay is there another example
besides Judas the you can think of yes
Paul refers to some of the early
disciples that were once partners with
them in taking the gospel to the
Gentiles and they eventually rebelled
and turned away well friends we're not
done we just taking a short break we'll
be right back
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
what if you could know the future what
would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named Rahm was violent they were
ruthless
they were determined the Gospel writers
see his death as a fulfillment of
salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking Bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com if you enjoy
hearing solid biblical answers on Bible
answers live you can have those same
insights at your fingertips through the
amazing facts prophecy Study Bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides plus a Bible
numbers and symbols charts and eight
pages of colorful maps this best-ever
Bible gives you a biblical cyclope 'dick
index words of Christ in red chronology
of the Old Testament
along with Doug bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy to seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five thirty eight seventy two seventy
five
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 left to hear
from you this evening we have just a few
lines still open this is a good time to
give us a call with your Bible question
not just before the break we were
talking to someone about the question of
can a saved person be lost well we do
have a book that I think anyone wanting
to learn more about this would find very
interesting it's free we'll be happy to
send it to anyone who calls and asks the
book is called can a saved man choose to
be lost and it gives you the good
biblical perspective of this subject
again
the books called can a saved man choose
to be lost if you'd like to receive that
call us on our resource phone line
that's eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven and we'll be happy
to send it to anyone who calls and asks
a next one of their behalf is calling
from
looks like Alabama Cola from Alabama
welcome to the program yes my question
is will Christian Athletes be free to
participate in their favorite sports in
the new heavens and the new earth
well well athletes be able
to play sports in the new heavens and
the new earth well you know I think
heaven is going to be filled with joys
and amusements and activities that we
can't even begin to imagine
I think the sports that a person might
participate in here on earth will be
somewhat I think it will lose its
interest or its importance when one
actually gets to heaven there are so
many one of the things that God has in
stores for those that love in the Bible
says you can't even begin to imagine
what about soaring to other worlds or
witnessing some of the vast creation of
God or your being the earth made new we
can barely imagine what it will be like
to someone that might be wondering well
you know I don't know how happy I'm
gonna be in heaven if I can't play my
favorite sport I think the most
important thing that one needs to
recognize is that no one in heaven is
going to be sad that they feel as though
they missing out on anything whatever
God has in store for those that love him
it's gonna make them completely and
totally happy
does that help a little bit yes that
certainly does thank you
all right you're welcome thanks you're
called a next caller that we have is
Kaitlyn listening from Florida Kaylin
welcome to the program Keelan I guess it
is healing from Florida going what's
killing you there all right we might
come back to Kela and we gonna go to
Steve California are you there get on it
Mary all right
and your question Steve how do you know
the Holy Spirit prayers okay your
question is how do you know if the Holy
Spirit is in you well first of all the
Bible tells us that we as Christians
need to walk by faith not by sight in
other words there are times when we both
sense and feel the presence of God in a
very real way and you know we know yes
the Holy Spirit is speaking to my heart
we might feel as though we've been moved
by the Holy Spirit or sometimes we hear
that still small voice is the Bible puts
it that prompts us to do something or
maybe just say something to some
else and we know that's the Holy Spirit
speaking to us other times however we
might not always feel as though the Holy
Spirit is with us but you might not
always have the peace that the Holy
Spirit brings it doesn't mean that the
Holy Spirit has left us rather it means
we need to exercise a little more faith
in God and trust in Him even if we don't
feel as though the Holy Spirit is with
us we have the promise Jesus has
promised us where he says I will never
leave you nor forsake you and we know
that jesus said to his disciples and he
says to us that he was to a saint to his
father in heaven and then he would send
the Holy Spirit to those that believed
in him
so I guess my counsel to you would be
trust Jesus take God at His Word
sometimes you'll feel the Holy Spirit in
a very strong powerful way other times
you might not sin so feel the presence
of the Holy Spirit doesn't mean the Holy
Spirit is not working in your heart and
life change how do you change it's the
Holy Spirit that works a change within
us that changed jesus said is like the
growing of a seed it's like the growing
of a plant now you can look at a plant
and stare at it for 15-20 minutes and
you might see no change occur and you
might wonder well maybe that plants not
growing but if you leave it for a few
weeks you come back and you look at it
and sure enough you've seen some change
some growth so it is with the change of
heart the new heart that the Bible
speaks of when we receive Jesus as our
personal Savior he promises to give us
the Holy Spirit and the Holy Spirit
begins to change us sometimes we might
see some dramatic changes other times we
might not see too much change taking
place in a heart it doesn't mean the
Holy Spirit's not working I think one of
the best ways that we can know that the
Holy Spirit is working within us is if
we stop and we look back over a life and
we ask yourself the question have I seen
God working in my life can I see how
that my attitudes have changed or my
desires have changed
is there a growing interest am i
learning more about God and of course
there is something practical we can do
to have the Holy Spirit work within us
and that is we need to spend time with
God the more time we spend in God's Word
the more time we spend in prayer that
allows the Holy Spirit to do even more
in our hearts and in our lives
okay so it's a process it is a process
sanctification is the work of a lifetime
it's not a one moment thing but everyday
if you give yourself to God and you pray
and say Lord I'm yours today please work
within me and then believe that he will
we can have confidence that God is gonna
finish the work that he started all
right thank you all right thanks for
your call Steve we do have a book
talking about the Holy Spirit and the
work of the Holy Spirit in the heart and
life of the believer it's called life in
the spirit and we'll be happy to send
this to anyone who calls and asks all
you'll need to do is call our resource
line that's eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven and you can
ask for the book called the life in the
spirit I'll be happy to send it out to
anyone who calls and asks if you have a
Bible question our phone line here to
the studio is 800 four six three seven
two nine seven again that number is
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven next four that we have is
Kenneth listening from Minnesota Kenneth
welcome to the program thank you and
your question well my question is coming
from Revelation chapter 4 okay well
joining us on the room in heaven and he
pointed for he said around the throne of
God and also all living creatures so my
question is pretty foreign who are they
a dangerous and a human being so okay
and mine unless person is a living
creature will it be one looks like a
lion the other is like a calf that can't
lose status piece of a man and the
fourth is like a flying eagle all these
symbolic or they will be real no all
right good question
let me start with the four living
creatures and then we'll talk about the
24 elders for those of you who might be
listening and you know the Bible in
front of you
we're talking about Revelation chapter 4
john envisioned
seize the heavenly throne room and he
sees God the Father seated upon his
throne the throne surrounding the throne
are these four living creatures and it
talks about them being full of eyes they
can see and all around them and they
constantly cry holy holy holy if you
compare that with some of the Old
Testament passages in Isaiah and Ezekiel
but who or what could these four living
creatures represent the it's interesting
to note the first as the face likened to
a lion a lion in the Bible is often
associated with kingship or royalty and
some see in the description of the lion
this first living creature as
representing Jesus before he came to the
earth he was King of Kings Lord of lords
he ruled the universe but then he laid
that all aside when he became a man the
second living creature around the throne
has the face likened to an ox or a calf
and an ox or a calf they were
sacrificial animals you could sacrifice
an ox it was also a beast of burden and
so people see in that maybe referring to
Jesus he came to bear asin's to die as
our sacrifice here on the earth and then
the third living creature it says has a
face like unto a man and people see in
that after Jesus rose from the dead and
ascended to heaven he is our high priest
representing us in heaven before the
Father in the heavenly sanctuary the
Bible speaks of Jesus has been the
second Adam in the New Testament and
then the fourth living creature has the
face of an eagle and some people see in
the Eagle Eagles often associated with
power and judgment and kingship and when
Jesus comes back he doesn't come back as
a priest but he comes back as king of
kings and Lord of lords coming to
execute judgment upon the wicked so in
the four living creatures we almost see
four phases of Christ's ministry in the
plan of redemption so that's kind of
interesting if you look at the symbols
there that we have in Revelation for now
the 24 elders who are they there are two
principle interpretations as to who they
might be the one is that the 24 elders
could be perhaps those who were
resurrected at the time of Christ's
resurrection
and ascended to heaven with him you
reading the Bible half the graves were
opened when Jesus rose from the dead and
he died and rose from the dead and many
of those who slept came forth and it's
believed that they were taking his first
fruits of the resurrection back to
heaven with Jesus the other idea is that
the 24 elders could be the
representatives of the unfallen worlds
in Hebrews chapter one we read how that
God created the world's and it's in the
plural form so there's other intelligent
beings other than us they haven't sent
only the human races and here on the
earth and of course the angels they join
Satan's rebellion in heaven the 24
elders are sometimes referred to as the
sons of God as described in in the book
of Job and you can also read in the Old
Testament where it talks about the Lord
reigning before he's elders gloriously
and that's also in the Old Testament so
a number of folks feel that the 24
elders could be the representatives of
these unfallen worlds that was a lot of
information Kenneth alright thanks for
your call we appreciate it by the way
that's one of my favorite books to
studies the book of Revelation let's see
our next caller that we have is Robert
listening from college place Washington
Robert welcome to the program thank you
pastor Ron hi and your question yes
since you're a man of Revelation I
wanted to ask regarding the seven
churches I know John wrote the seven
churches were all in in existence when
when John wrote them but then how do we
know that they're also supposed to be
for for the part-time good question in
the book of Revelation of course
Revelation is a symbolic book and we
find symbols throughout the book of
Revelation talks about dragons to expel
a Roman standing upon the moon clothed
with the Sun you've got all kinds of
symbols so we know it's a symbolic book
but these symbols teach lessons and when
you look at the seven churches we notice
it's the first series of seven so you've
got seven churches you got seven
seals and then you have seven trumpets
the seven churches the seven seals and
the seven trumpets cover the Christian
era from the time of Christ all the way
up to the second coming and each of
those seven churches represent seven
phases that the Christian Church as a
whole would go through during the
Christian era today we find ourselves in
the last church the Church of Laodicea
the conditions described to the Church
of Laodicea our conditions that we see
in the Christian Church today
spiritual lukewarmness and when you look
at the conditions of the church
described in Ephesus while those are the
conditions of the early Christian Church
from about thirty one to 180 the next
church is the Church of Smyrna it is a
church that suffered persecution and we
find in history that is exactly what
happened from about 100 to 313 ad there
was intense persecution that came
against the church so yes even though
these were real churches and without a
doubt the conditions described in the
different churches related to specific
things in those churches but they had a
broader and fuller application and
that's how we can see the parallels
between the seven churches and the Seven
phases of the Christian Church okay
makes sense thank you
yeah I think if you call we appreciate
that
you're listening to Bible answers live
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific time call us at
[Music]
1-877-774-6473 to an animal I I don't
think really does much good because the
animal doesn't understand it can't
understand the Bible tells us that when
we pray we need to pray to God the
disciples came to Jesus one day and said
teach us to pray and Jesus said when you
pray say our Father which is in heaven
it's probably not a good thing to pray
to anything else other than God even
you know idolatry people would pray to
idols and the Bible condemns that so
pray needs to be sainted towards God
doesn't mean that animals can't be a
blessing they are God gave them to us
but I don't think any Christian should
be praying to anything or anyone other
than God
thanks for call me Frank next call is an
either listening from New York Amita
welcome to the program thank you good
evening I do have a question referencing
to what Jesus Christ said when he was on
the cross if he knew that he was a
sacrificial lamb and he died for us why
did he ask God God why have you forsaken
me this purpose in life on earth okay
Jesus when he went to the cross it
actually began a little early in the
Garden of Gethsemane where jesus began
to bear the sins of the world and that's
why Jesus prayed in the Garden of
Gethsemane said father if it is possible
let this cup pass from me nevertheless
not my will die will be done Jesus
experienced the agony of soul and felt
the separation from his father because
he took upon himself the sins of the
world he was separated from the father
he was overwhelmed by a sense of justice
enormity of guilt not his own guilt but
the guilt of the sins of the world that
Christ took upon himself he felt as
though he was forsaken of the Father now
his faith endured Jesus remained
faithful he said not my world I will be
done it's also interesting to note that
when Jesus was hanging on the cross and
he cried out my God my God why have you
forsaken me Jesus is actually quoting
from Psalm 22 the people that were there
at the cross and many of them Jews they
knew the Old Testament they knew the
Book of Psalms when Jesus quoted my God
my God why you forsaken me
they were probably many in the crowd
that went back and read Psalm 22 and
that's where Jesus was quoting from and
when you read Psalm 22 it's a powerful
prophetic description of what would
happen to Jesus talking about his
crucifixion
and his experience it's a prophetic
messianic passage so in saying that
Jesus was directing the people around
the cross to go look at the scriptures
help them unto help them understand what
was happening and who Jesus was
now I understand thank you so much
wonderful programming thank you for
calling in it yes the phone I mean not
the phone line but the verse I mentioned
there is Psalm 22 I encourage you to
take a look at that I think you'll find
that helpful again friends if you have a
Bible question not too late to call our
phone line here to the studio is 800 for
six three seven two nine seven and we'll
try to get your Bible question on the
air before our program ends our next
caller that we have is Elizabeth
listening from Michigan Elizabeth
welcome to the program thank you for the
welcome glory to God for your service to
the community and the listeners and
praise God for the good news and thanks
for taking the call and I can't wait to
get out amazing facts toward I just
found you tonight I was on my way to
church and tuned in on the way home and
thank you for taking my question oh
absolutely and you're welcome and your
question tonight
my question is and why do I feel
challenged in the failed marriage of
marital vows um my husband and I close
to 10 years on when I feel that his
experience or karma or choices are have
taken him away from Jesus and it ends up
being guilt or shame or my choice they
have to end the marriage or til death do
us apart even though it is adultery
addiction and abuse and I feel like the
space there's a question on me is a
matter of you know I I know Jesus died
for all of our sins and I know that it's
not anyone's intention to be bad or
turned away from sin but my shame or
guilt or like suffering is wondering how
that would not be of God's will okay so
perhaps your question if I understand it
correctly is why is it that you feel
or experience this this pain in having
to in your case it sounds like having to
end a marriage because of an
unwillingness of your spouse to be
faithful to the marriage vows is that
correct yeah okay
well you know I think first of all the
way God designed marriage from the very
beginning it is to be the most sacred
tie on earth it is very special
it's a powerful bond and God purposed it
to be that way whenever a marriage ends
it is a very difficult thing it's a
painful experience that people go
through especially the one who wants the
marriage to work
and he's struggling because the spouse
is refusing to make the commitment
that's needed for that marriage to work
and it's a lot of pain there's a lot of
hurt that's involved in any marriage
that comes to an end and I think what
you're experiencing is just a very real
experience of anyone that's going
through your situation without a doubt
it's not an easy situation and I think
through this the best thing to do is to
just really cling to Jesus spend time on
your knees spend time in his word ask
for grace and strength you might find a
good Christian framed that you can
counsel with maybe a pastor at the
church to kind of give you some
resources some guidance to carry you
through this but I think what you're
experiencing is a very normal experience
that someone would have going through
this difficult experience you know
Elizabeth we do have a book that we
would be happy to send you you can read
it for free online at the amazing facts
website it's called marriage divorce and
remarriage and it talks about gives some
good Bible counsel on what one is to do
and they find themselves in these
difficult situations you have to make
those tough choices when it comes to
marriage marriage is a very special
thing that God ordained whenever a
marriage comes to an end it is a
difficult painful experience but God is
able to carry you through that I just
don't encourage you to cling to him hold
on to him and he will be with you every
step of the way I want to thank you for
your call a look Elizabeth our next call
is Dan listening from Brookland Dan
welcome to the
good evening bastard hi I'm Jewish and I
listen to your program every Sunday
night I never listen oh and I love Jesus
also by the way amen
I'm interested in translation especially
Luther how could he possibly translate
the Hebrew Bible into German when he
didn't know Hebrew didn't study Hebrew
and hated Jews just because you know
well let me back up a little bit before
Luther became the leader of the
Reformation he was a very devout monk
and one of the things that the monks
would do they would learn the biblical
languages not all of them but many of
them did and without a doubt I'm sure
Martin Luther put tremendous amount of
time and effort he was very committed to
the Lord very committed to the Bible to
the word and he spent time studying the
ancient languages even in his time there
were books available where one could
read and learn the different languages
the biblical languages both Hebrew and
Greek and I think a lot of the work
before the Reformation when he was still
studying and learning laying the
foundation for the Reformation that's
when he was able to read and learn and
study so that's that's when he learned
Hebrew was during that time period you
know you know pastor when when I read
the 23rd song even if I read it a
hundred times it's so so beautiful it's
just it's just unbelievable absolutely
well that is a great psalm indeed I
think that's the psalm that everyone
should memorize because it really
displays God's love and he's concerned
for his people and how he's willing to
take care of us pastor pastor yes I'm
here really reading people should really
read the H song what has been that -
made him a little lower than the Angels
mm-hmm yes yeah a wonderful wonderful
line that's right you know these are
many of those beautiful passages
inscription you know the Bible
the Bible is filled with wonderful
promises that people can lay ahold of
they can claim they make it their own it
can help to sustain them during those
difficult times that they go through the
Bible is filled with these promises and
I'd like to encourage all of our
listeners if you haven't begun to put to
memory some of these wonderful Bible
promises I would encourage you to do so
it is a great time to do that well
friends we want to thank you for being
part of our Bible answer live program
this evening if we didn't get to your
call tonight I encourage you to call
back next week as we continue to study
the Bible god bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
amazing facts offer some of the best
Christian resources for all ages we have
our products will enrich your life and
your walk with the Lord
what does Bible prophecy reveal about
the world's two largest religions
explore the ancient conflict in Islam
Christianity and prophecy a compelling
three-part series with pastor Doug
Batchelor get yours today by calling
[Music]
855-578-6767
5 1 the number again eight seven seven
five zero six one seven five one or just
visit
give dot amazing facts Oh our G or send
your gift two P o box
10:58 Roseville California nine five six
seven eight thank you for studying the
Word of God with me today
I hope that you plan now to join me
again next week as we discover more
amazing facts from the Word of God for
over 50 years
amazing faxes shared the wonderful news
of salvation and provided millions of
Bible resources to people all over the
world
we built churches in India proclaim
God's Word in China and have sent free
Bible studies around the globe today's
program and free resources were made
possible by our ministry partners caring
individuals like you if you've been
blessed by amazing facts would you
please consider partnering with us to
reach others with the Bible truth your
financial support today will help keep
programs like this on the air
so the blessings you've received can be
shared with others to find out more
about becoming a ministry partner please
visit our website
you